hello natalie huge congratulations
thank you thank you so much i'm so happy
to be talking to you
all right i absolutely loved the movie
and i needed it right now
i wanted to go back to getting the green
light for this one because i know that
the blacklist wound up being
a big deal for you as a writer but i
don't know was there any particular
person or
thing that happened that made going into
production with this idea
a reality for you um such a good
question
you know as you said this script was on
the blacklist nearly 10 years ago
i wrote it when i was like in my mid-20s
a struggling writer like
trying to make it in la and it opened a
lot of doors for me and it came
really close a few times but it never
quite like
came over that hump and i think
sometimes for
you know your readers who are and
viewers who are you know uh
screenwriters you know
that like sometimes a script is like an
ex-boyfriend or an ex
you just have to like put it away and
move on and i had done that
and then about five years ago when i was
pregnant with my first child
no trace camping who's the producer
financier of this film
approached me and they were like you
know we really want to make this movie
we love this script
we need you to rewrite it quick rewrite
which any writer can tell you is an
oxymoron
um and you know just do the work and
like let's go ahead and it was like an
ex begging me to get back together i was
like
okay it's not gonna be different this
time but i'll humor you
and i did it and i dove in and we had a
lot of conversations about what i
thought the movie looked like and felt
like
and you know when i was done they kind
of said why don't you direct it
and i was like what do i have to do do i
have to like make a real or act it out
for you what do you need me to do
and they said no you know exactly what
it is just
say yes like you can do it and um
that's so rare for a female director in
hollywood
i said um okay well thank you for
letting me know what it feels like to be
a straight white guy
i accept and i will do it maybe my next
movies like jurassic park tbd
um and i just dove in and it's been
honestly the greatest experience of my
life it's been so much fun
doing as a jurassic park obsessed
individual i am fully behind the idea of
you doing another jurassic world movie
okay let's let's put that into the world
let's put that into the universe
that's what these interviews are for
aren't they get it out there
yeah so this is this uh was something
that you wrote a long time ago
between i don't know just your growth as
a person
between making the idea more modern
incorporating technology we're doing now
what would you say is the biggest
difference between that original version
and what we see on screen now
some of the things that stayed the same
was really like lucy's essence she kind
of was an extension of me
in it's her own way you know in my 20s
and so i think
she's a character who asks the you know
the world to love her
not despite the fact that she is weird
but because
she is weird which i think is like the
most important
thing for young women to know that like
that's
how hopefully love works um
and then of course you know i like i
i've kind of said this before
anytime someone asks a writer to read
something that they wrote like
ten five six years ago like i'd rather
be buried alive than have to go back
and look at that but writing is a muscle
and you know you kind of learn a ton
about
story and pacing and plot so some of the
kind of mechanics
of the story really changed as you
mentioned technology and
you know um kind of the the pacing and
things like that
but the soul of the story always stayed
the same
i also really wanted to ask you about
working with your casting directors here
because your lead
it's not even just your leads that are
good you have smaller characters
that get their time in the spotlight and
really make the most
of it so what is the key for you to
having a good collaboration with your
casting team
we had such a great casting team and we
really had a casting team
that embraced kind of like thinking
outside of the
usual box and the usual like
you know this is you know this person
should be this way or this person should
be that way we really
kind of tried to kind of find these
little gems
to sort of put in our film and i think
that
one of the great things with casting
directors not just them
alerting you to a read for a particular
part but also
being able to my casting directors were
really showing me
a lot of like you know where my actors
had appeared
in other roles and i think that's so
informative for a director i think
most of my choices weren't necessarily
based on a read and were much more based
on like
where i had seen these actors before and
where i had seen them shine
um and they all you know without
exception
gave me the performance of a lifetime in
this film so i'm
very very grateful to all of them i
cheated and i read that you mentioned
brittany runs a marathon in another
interview and that was my favorite movie
of last year so if that
if that paved the way to this for
woodkarsh i'm really rooting for him
yes it definitely did that paved the way
for lukash blockers paved the way for
geraldine
um for molly snl for ego broad city for
arturo
like i could go on you know you named a
lot of very good ones there
um speaking of molly i'm a big genre fan
horror genre fan i have to ask what
inspired the choice to make her
character obsessed with death um you
know
i think that actually comes from my own
girlfriends i have to be honest
like my favorite murder is one of i
think like the best
podcasts around um and uh
it's just something that like i have a
friend that this character is
sort of loosely based on and her way of
sh we joke that her way of showing
affection is through violence
um so when when molly kind of says i
love you so much i'm gonna push you down
the stairs that is something that has
been said to me
and um i take it with all the love that
it's intended
it's a real art to be able to express
that and have it come across that way
but she pulls it off
she manages that another one of my
absolute favorite parts of the movie
is just the group of friends lucy amanda
and nadine i i really could watch an
entire series of just them
living their life in the city so is all
of that i guess the banter and comedic
timing going back and forth between them
is all of that
scripted and planned or is some of that
naturally coming up on set
as a director one of the best things you
can do
is i i say this all the time a movie is
directed in prep
and by that i mean that like we really
worked those scenes
and we really made sure that they they
worked and they were funny and like they
went back and forth and that dynamic
was rich and natural but
because i had such strong comedians
once you kind of nail the way that it is
on the page you really have an
opportunity
even in a small budget movie like this
to play a little bit and because we
prepared so well
i was able to kind of like let them run
wild and so
the answer to your question is it's kind
of a hybrid it's partially
what was on the page and then partially
just like
these incredible actresses improvising
and adding their own zingers to this
which kind of took it to i think the
next level
the three of them are great i know the
movie is kind of about
letting things go but did you keep any
memorabilia from the production
oh my god well i kept you know
i have a ton of photos from that time
and geraldine actually made me this
really beautiful scrapbook which i have
kept so like i have some confetti that
we
um you know through in the last scene
and a lot of polaroids and then one of
the things that i really
um i'm going to make hopefully someone
lets me do this again a tradition
on my sets is that my first day um first
couple days
on directing this movie i um
took uh photos of a polaroid of every
single person on the crew
and had their name and their role and
that was a way for me to learn
everyone's name but it's also kind of
like a yearbook from the movie and so
i think uh that's kind of gonna be my
ongoing sentimentalist
tradition moving forward i can't even
tell you how much i love that idea
i want to see everyone do it oh i hate
to let you go but i gotta leave
such a pleasure talking to you you too
thanks so much congratulations again
thanks